we've just watched a film on the high
street it's clearly a really hard time
for so many businesses and the ippr
estimates that more than half a million
could go under this spring without more
government support what's your analysis
that's absolutely right and i think the
wider point is that uh we are still in
the crisis
obviously there's a roadmap out of it
but you keep asking the question
should we be moving to solve the public
finances now or should we be dealing
with a crisis
and i'm absolutely clear on this we have
got to sustain the support for
businesses
until we get to the other side of this
and perhaps the thing to reflect on
is all of the things that the chancellor
has already done
will almost be in vain if lots of
businesses fail in the next three months
so i'm categorically in that camp and of
course that does mean
the high street businesses yes welcome
the money that's been talked about today
but we've got to think about some of the
underlying points as well and of course
that includes business rates reform
and just to unpick some of what you said
there you're talking about the support
needed to continue
otherwise businesses will fail what kind
of time frame are you
um talking about i thought it was pretty
clear from rishi sunak that
you know they want to extend the support
to the end of the road map which is in
june
but do you think that actually some of
the support or needs to actually go a
bit further
well it's interesting because business
is not sort of uniform is it here
so quite rightly there's a lot of talk
about the businesses that have been most
seriously affected that's what your film
just talked about and i hope that for
them it really is a question
of getting to the reopening perhaps a
little bit on that because anyone who's
running a business knows that the period
in which you're
gearing back up is also very vulnerable
in cash flow
so but i'm optimistic that by the summer
we will see that consumer-led
recovery but there are other businesses
where the
other sectors where the damage is much
much lower long-term let's go to the
other extreme perhaps an
aerospace business lots of those in the
west midlands they are not
suddenly going to bounce back they've
still got lots of people on furlough
their levels of demand are very low and
the way they're going to need to come
back
is by investing in new kittens for the
upturn
and that's all about the sort of tax
advantages for them
and that is a much much longer burn that
some of those really competitive sectors
will be able to come back strongly it's
interesting because you're touching
there on sort of long-term
tax reform business rates for example to
help the high street things
directed at certain industries to help
their
working climate be a bit more attractive
what kind of things do you want to see
well i think the first thing around tax
that we're already seeing actually is
the tax on
jobs or the encouragement of businesses
to take more people on
the primary challenge i'll be honest
about the situation in the west midlands
85 000 more people claiming uh universal
credit benefits
than this time last year that is an
enormous change
so the headroom that the chancellor may
still have left
have already i think been applied quite
wisely to some of the business
advantages taking on apprentices so that
3 thousand pound allowance there
the kickstart scheme obviously and then
of course what's
also uh being done hopefully around
there's a talk in the papers today about
national insurance holidays for
recruiting
so that would all try to make it more
attractive for businesses
to recruit people but then we're also
going to need to think about what helps
companies invest in the long term and
the old
the best approach there is definitely
tax allowance against investment
what about corporation tax a lot of
discussion around uh potential rises to
corporation tax do you think that would
be
a good idea to try and get the public
finances in order
well let's take the question a little
bit more broadly then we'll come back to
corporation tax head on
i mean obviously we have got to over
time
address the public finances anyone who
denies that
i'm afraid is denying the reality but as
your first question juror
it's a question of when and it's also
true to say
that we say we've all been in this
together but actually some
sectors have had better times and some
individuals have had better times
so it is going to be necessary to see
some tax rises in the areas that have
probably done better
so you know the talk about online online
taxes i i do again say categorically
that is the right thing to do
they have had a good time it is right
they bear a little bit more of the
burden
on corporation tax i would regret it
personally because i do think britain's
very competitive corporation tax has
been right
but i would fully accept there are some
really tough choices for the chancellor
and if the end judgment is that's going
to go up a few points as he's talked
about in the papers today we'd still be
relatively competitive
and i would accept that possibly as a
price to pay
um you mentioned online tax and it's
it's a fiendishly difficult
place to tax because of the
international
uh global state of affairs and what kind
of things
could the chancellor look at i mean
there's for example on the sunday
telegraph today
reports of new tax on online deliveries
is that the kind of thing that you think
would work
you could do i mean you could you can
have an online sales tax it could be
really very blunt like that and of
course
the delivery tax has been talked about
but also actually informal business
rates would
if you just change the balance of
contribution between
high street premises and say
distribution warehouses you can tilt to
different sectors of the economy so
there are ways of doing it
and you're of course talking to us from
birmingham and mayor of the west
midlands and how concerned are you
about the pandemic's impact on the
leveling up
agenda it's really interesting question
actually
because what we have seen is that
pre-pandemic this place the economy was
performing
really well we had the fastest growth of
any region outside london over the
previous 10 years actually record
employment numbers great investment
but very sadly it looks as though we may
be the worst affected region so from
best to worse
is pretty uh dramatic so there is an
effect
but what will ultimately drive levelling
up is
all of the work around retraining
opportunity skills
and we can continue to do that and
actually in the region we continued
to try to make great progress on that so
if i was asking for one thing
around leveling up it wouldn't
necessarily about be about
roads and bridges and all of that it
actually let's really concentrate
on the retraining of the people who've
lost their job and get them ready for
the industries of the future
and in our case the whole electric
vehicle industry is critical
and of course the digital sector and
just one step i think your viewers found
interesting so free
all the retraining we're doing in
digital anyone who goes through our
schemes
almost anyone is employed after them
there are still parts of the economy
that are growing and that's where the
retraining needs to be focused
are you worried that the government's
taken its eye off the leveling up agenda
that it talked about so much during the
election
uh no i'm not actually uh i am i would
be gosh
uh almost superhuman not to have uh had
to move
complete focus to tackling the pandemic
of course and so perhaps some of the
things that we would otherwise have seen
haven't uh come through i i would accept
that but actually is there an
utter commitment to it we've heard about
the leveling up fund for example
the commitment of infrastructure spend
in the regions is absolutely there i
hope we're going to hear about the towns
fund
that's a good practical frontline piece
around leveling up and as i say
a lot of money is being committed on
this retraining and that will in the
long term
be the best way of raising opportunity
in places like this
i asked richard cena about the roadmap
out of lockdown as well he made it very
clear that the dates given are the
earliest dates
at which things can be eased
but at the same time if it's data driven
should they also be prepared to speed
things up
if the data is better than expected we
know of course they're willing to slow
things down if things
aren't going in the way that they want
so
um let me try to explain why i think
what's been said is logical and um
i haven't sort of had this described to
me by those in central government but my
own working out of it is
at each stage we have got to assess the
progress
we know that frankly when we unlocked
after the second lockdown
the virus banks back up what wrote the
time delays in the roadmap
are to see that we have not got an
increase
from each stage of it and then if you so
if you look at the three weeks then the
five weeks to me
that is logical because if you act
on the next thing before you know with
the lead time around the spread of the
virus
what's happened with the previous stage
you may be making the wrong
judgment i personally i asked for a
cautious approach to this
in the west midlands we still have a
pretty stubborn level of infections
about 169 per hundred thousand
so for us and the overwhelming reaction
from business there this week has been
yes understand why that cautious but
steady approach is there
because it allows us to assess progress
as i've described so we will never have
to go back
at the same time though lockdown of
course has consequences too we just
heard from paul johnson of the
institute for fiscal um studies who said
you know every week of additional
lockdown is costing not just the economy
but it's also costing so many people
so much in terms of their mental health
their education their work and
everything else
it should be moved as quickly as
possible consistent with doing it safely
if we can do it quicker we absolutely
should
you disagree then no if we if we
absolutely can and all the evidence is
pointing at that
of course i'm sure no one would wish to
say no to that
what i tried to do was explain why i
think it is utterly
logical that the time delays in the plan
are
as they are i would definitely like it
to go faster goodness
i lead the region that's had a terrible
effect in every sense
but i do think that it is far more
important that we do this
once and for all and get it right and
never risk the bounce back
that we saw actually twice in the second
half of last year